cut [ __ ] do ah top I do much because
Vivienne feels there is a mission up in
space called the Lisa Pathfinder doing
some experiments and it's a slightly
strange mission in the what it's got
it's got two little gold cubes out there
and the slightly strange thing about it
is the the point of the experiment in
some sense isn't the spacecraft around
them it's the two little gold cubes in
the middle its beginning of the
development of the next generation of
gravitational wave detectors so LIGO has
demonstrated that we can detect
gravitational waves but gravitational
waves are waves right so they have a
wavelength associated with them or of
characteristic frequency and LIGO is
able to measure waves that I've got a
frequency of about 100 Hertz if there is
a correct and the beginning to look like
they're correct general relativity tells
you that we can produce gravitational
waves over a whole range of wavelengths
and frequencies in particular we can
produce very large wavelength events if
two galaxies merge together and we know
that happens the Centers of the two
galaxies of supermassive black holes in
them and we know that they're going to
combine and begin to go around and
they'll go around much slower than the
30 solar mass black holes that we've
seen the corresponding gravitational
waves will have a much lower frequency
or a much higher wavelength so in order
to detect them you've actually got to go
beyond the earth you've actually got to
go out into space and the whole idea of
the experiment is to find out whether
you really can have these sort of
free-floating little cubes and whether
you can put an entire spacecraft around
them and they still essentially remain
as free-floating cubes so really the
cubes to just floating there and the
spacecraft has to stay in the right
place to keep them you know not to nudge
the cube in any way so the boxes are in
the Lisa Pathfinder but not touching the
walls of the Lisa Pathfinder they're
just following Lisa pathfinders on a you
know on a free fall trajectory and these
boxes are as well of course that's
actually I mean you know physically
that's not so hard to do because
actually can have a little cube and then
because it's you know you're out there
in space so it's actually just going to
hang there and you could put a
spacecraft around it but of course as
soon as the cube starts to charge up a
little bit if there's any electric
charge on the satellite around it that's
going to start pulling it one way on the
if there are magnetic fields in there
that's going to start pulling it around
so the question is whether you can
really effectively put this whole space
probe around the cube and it not
disturbed the cube in any way Lisa
Pathfinder went up was launched in
December it's about one and a half
million kilometres from Earth between
the Earth and the Sun where the
gravitational potential the pull of the
Sun on the on the Lisa Pathfinder
exactly balances the pull of the earth
and the gravitational so the two little
cubes in there they're about 40
centimeters apart and so actually
they're doing experiments to see whether
they can sort of figure out the distance
between them and maintain the station
between them of that distance they're
trying to see how well they can measure
the differences so that they can
understand what's causing the
differences a they've got to be able to
understand what forces are acting on
these bodies there's there's solar wind
there's various pressures from things
like the solar wind and particles and so
they're following the trajectory of
these objects and they've discovered
that the sensitivity that their
experiment can reach is already I think
at least five times better than they
think they will need for the actual
mission so this is sort of technology
proving they're really just trying to
figure out what the limits are what you
can do and the big goal here is they
want to scale the whole thing up that
basically at the moment these two cubes
are about 40 centimeters apart they want
to do an experiment where the two little
gold cubes are actually a million
kilometres apart and if you put the two
cubes a million kilometres apart that's
a really quite exciting science you can
start doing the complete mission will
actually have three spacecraft this is
the thing called ELISA which I think
stands for the evolved laser
interferometers space antenna or
something like that anyway but it's
basically an experiment to detect
gravitational waves and they're going to
have three of these spacecraft out there
one's going to have two cubes in it and
then you have two other ones which have
one cube in each in the in the final
experiment what you've got is you've got
this constellation of three satellites
that are kind of following the earth
around to the Earth's in orbit around
the Sun you've got this constellation of
three satellites they're all in separate
orbits around the Sun going to more or
less tracking the Earth's orbit but
they're all slightly inclined orbits and
so the net effect of that is as they
track around they kind of rotate around
and so you've got the earth going around
the Sun these satellites following us
along and kind of this rotating
constellation of three satellites and
essentially
there are kind of two pairs of cubes in
that way so you've got the kind of two
arms of this this gravitational wave
telescope the other really important
thing is can you measure exactly where
the cube is within the spacecraft so
part of the experiment is actually to
determine the position of the cube
within the spacecraft and that's partly
just to make sure the spacecraft stays
in the right place but it's also because
of the way this experiment works the way
the experiment the full-size experiment
works is you need to measure the
distance between these two little cubes
because when one of these gravitational
waves goes past space shrinks and
expands a little bit and so the distance
between them shifts a little bit the way
you measure the distance between these
cubes is you actually measure the
distance between the two spacecraft and
then you measure the distance between
the spacecraft and the cube or we're
within the spacecraft the cube is at
each end and by combining those three
bits of information that basically tells
you how to far apart the two cubes
actually are and so part of what they're
doing with just this one spacecraft is
figuring out quite how accurately they
can measure where within the spacecraft
the cube is exactly to within you know a
tiny fraction of the size of an atom so
you want something which is fairly
nonreactive so it's not outgassing so
it's not kind of jet propelling itself
around than doing anything else that
might move it around you want something
which is reflective because actually
you're bouncing laser beams off these
things in order to measure exactly where
they are because they're using these
techniques called interferometry which
involves bouncing a laser beam backwards
and forwards to actually figure out
exactly where the cube is so you just
want something which is sort of very
passive but also reflects light so as
one of these waves goes past there they
really are just literally expansions and
contractions of space so so these cubes
will as space expands and contracts
between them get a little further apart
and a little closer together and
depending on what the Astrophysical
sources which is producing the
gravitational waves as we've seen with
the LIGO experiment you would get these
very characteristic signatures and you
can actually use that to infer a lot
about what it is that's produced the
gravitational wave in the first place
you see it's so excited about spaceships
and you chose the wrong job if you give
me an engineering job on a spaceship
then that thing wouldn't fly they'll
merge into a bigger black hole right and
so they merge into this bigger black
hole which actually is estimated to be
about to think 62 solar mass black hole
and this the remnant energy that they're
still energy left